so we've got a very interesting scenario
here I have this conical thimble like
cup that is four centimeters high and
also the diameter of the top of the cup
is also four centimeters and I'm pouring
water into this cup right now and I'm
pouring the water at a rate of one cubic
centimetre one cubic centimeter per
second and right at this moment there is
a height of two centimeters of water in
the cup right now so the height right
now from the bottom of the cup to this
point right over here is 2 centimeters
so my question to you is at what rate we
know the rate at which the water is
flowing into the cup or give it we're
being given a volume per time my
question to you is right at this moment
right when we are filling our cup at 1
cubic centimeter per second and we have
exactly 2 centimeters of water in the
cup 2 centum it's 2 centimeters deep of
water in the cup what is the rate at
which the height of the water is
changing what is the rate at which what
is the rate at which this height right
over here is actually changing we know
it's 2 centimeters but how fast is it
changing well let's think about this a
little bit what are we being given we're
given we're being given the rate at
which the volume of the water is
changing with respect to time so let's
write that down we're being given the
rate at which the volume of the water is
changing with respect to time and where
it's being told we were told that this
is one cubic centimeter one cubic
centimeter per second and what are we
trying to figure out what we're trying
to figure out how fast the height of the
water is changing with respect to time
we know that the height right now is 2
centimeters but what we want to figure
out is the rate at which the height is
changing the height is changing with
respect to time if we can figure out
this then we have essentially answered
the question so one way that we can do
this is if we can come up with a
relationship between the volume at any
moment in time and the height at any
moment in time and then maybe take the
derivative of that relationship possibly
using the chain rule to come up with a
relationship between the rate at which
the volume is changing and the rate at
the height is changing so let's try to
do it step by step so first of all can
we come up with a relationship between
the volume and the height at any given
at any given moment well we have also
been given the formula for the volume of
a cone right over here the volume of a
cone is 1/3 times the area of the base
of the cone times the height and we
won't prove it here although we could
prove it later on especially when we
start doing solids of revolutions with
in in integral calculus but we'll just
take it on faith right now but this is
how we can figure out the volume of a
cone so given this can we figure out
volume can we figure out an expression
that relates volume to the height of the
cone well we could say that volume and
I'll do it in this I'll do this blue
color the volume of water is what we
really care about the volume of water is
going to be equal to 1/3 times the area
of the surface of the water the area of
the surface of the water area of water
surface water surface times our height
of the water so times H so how can we
figure out the area of the water surface
preferably in terms of H well we see
right over here the diameter across the
top of the cone is 4 centimeters and the
height of the the whole cup is 4
centimeters and so that ratio is going
to be true of any when it will at any
depth of water it's always going to have
the same ratio between the diameter
across the top and the height because
these are lines right over here so at
any given point the ratio between this
and this is going to be the same so at
any given point the diameter across the
surface of the water if the depth is H
the diameter across the surface of the
water is also going to be H and so from
that we can figure out what it radius is
going to be the radius is going to be H
over 2 and so the area of the water
surface is going to be PI R squared pi
times the radius squared H over 2
squared that's the area of the surface
of the water and of course we still have
the 1/3 out here and we're still and
we're still multiplying by this H over
here so let me see if I can simplify
this so this gives us 1
third times pi h squared PI H squared
over four times another H which is equal
to we have PI H to the third power H to
the third power over 12 so that is our
volume now what we want to do is relate
the volume how fast the volume is
changing with respect to time and how
fast the height is changing with respect
to time so we care with respect to time
let's take care so much about what's
happening with respect to time let's
take the derivative of both sides of
this equation with respect to time to do
that and just so I have enough space to
do that let me move this over let me
move this over to the right a little bit
so I just move this over to the right
and so now we can take the derivative
with respect to time of both sides of
this business so the derivative with
respect to time of our volume and the
derivative with respect to time of this
business well the derivative with
respect to time of our volume we can
just rewrite that as DV DT this thing
right over here this is d V DT and this
is going to be equal to well we could
take the constants out of this this is
going to be equal to PI over 12 PI over
12 times the derivative with respect to
T times the derivative with respect to T
of H of H to the third power of H to the
third power and just so that the next
few things I do will appear a little bit
clearer we're assuming that height is a
function of time in fact it's definitely
a function of time as time goes on the
height will change because we're pouring
more and more water here so instead of
just writing H to the 3rd power which I
could write over here let me write H of
T to the third power just to make it
clear that this is a function of T H of
T to the third power now what is the
derivative with respect to T of H of T
to the third power now you might be
getting a tingling feeling that the
chain rule might be applicable here so
let's think about the chain rule the
chain rule tells us let me rewrite
everything else DV with respect to T is
going to be
equal to is going to be equal to PI over
12 times the derivative of this with
respect to T and we want to take the
derivative of this with respect to T we
have something to the third power
so we want to take the derivative of
that of something to the third power
with respect to something so that's
going to be let me write this in a
different color maybe an orange so
that's going to be three times R
something squared three times R
something squared times times the
derivative of that something with
respect to T times D H let me I've
already used that pink times times D H
DT let's just be very clear this orange
term right over here and I'm just using
the chain rule this is the derivative of
this is the derivative of H of T H of T
to the third power with respect to H of
T with respect to H of T and then we're
going to multiply that times the
derivative of H of T the derivative of H
of T with respect to T and then that
gives us the derivative of this entire
thing H of T to the third power with
respect to T this will give us the
derivative the derivative of H of T to
the third power with respect to with
respect to D with respect to T which is
exactly what we want to do when we apply
this operator how fast is this changing
how is this changing with respect to
time so we can just rewrite this just so
it gets a little bit cleaner let me
rewrite everything I've done so we got
DV the rate at which our volume is
changing with respect to time the rate
at which our volume is changing with
respect to time is equal to PI over 12
is equal to PI over 12 times 3 H of T
squared or I could just write that as 3
H squared 3 H squared times the rate at
which the height is changing with
respect to time times d h dt times d h
dt times d h dt and you might be a
little confused you might have been
tempted to take the derivative the
derivative over here
with respect to age but remember we're
thinking about how things are changing
with respect to time so we're assuming
we did Express volume as a function of
height but we're saying that height
itself as a function of time so we're
taking the derivative of everything with
respect to time so that's why the chain
rule came into play when we were taking
the derivative of H or the derivative of
H of T because we're assuming that H is
a function of time now what does this
thing right over here get us well we're
telling us at the exact moment that we
set up this problem we know what DV DT
is we know that it's one centimeter
cubed per second we know that this right
over here is 1 centimeter cubed per
second we know what our height is right
at this moment we were told it is 2
centimeters our height right over here
we know it is 2 centimeters so the only
unknown we have over here is the rate at
which our height is changing with
respect to time which is exactly what we
needed to figure out in the first place
so we just have to solve for that so we
get one cubic centimeter let me make it
clear we get one cubic centimeter one
cubic centimeter per second I won't
write the unit's to save some space is
equal to PI over 2 and I'll write this
in a neutral color actually let me write
it the same color is equal to PI over 2
times 3 times 3 times H squared H is 2
so you're going to get 4 squared
centimeters we kept the unit's so 3
times 4 or let me be careful that's that
wasn't PI over 2 that was PI over 12
this is a PI over 12 right over your PI
over 12 so you get PI over 12 times 3
times 2 squared times dhdt times d h dt
all of this is equal to 1 so now I'll
switch to a neutral color we get 1 is
equal to well 3 times 4 is 12 cancels
out with that 12 we get 1 is equal to pi
times D h dt to solve for d h dt divide
both sides by PI and we get we get our
drumroll now the rate at which our
height is changing with respect to time
as we're putting one cubic centimeter of
water per second in and right when our
height is 2 centimeters side there
rate at which this height is changing
with respect to time is one over one
over PI and I haven't done the
dimensional analysis but this is going
to be in centimeters in centimeters per
second you could work through the
dimensional analysis if you like by
putting the dimensions right over here
but there you have it that's how fast
our height is going to be changing at
exactly that moment